nous sommes cours fauriel à
saint-etienne et nous allons pénétrer
dans cette villa pour faire connaissance
avec la famille landes voici solange 12
ans toujours en pleine action rosel 15
ans préfère une distraction beaucoup
plus calme elle crée des personnages et
des paysages de cartons florence 14 ans
a choisi le piano
hélène 19 ans se repose en tricotant
pendant que monsieur landais et lit son
journal et que madame landais prépare un
petit plat dont elle a le secret ce
n'est pas tout monsieur et madame
landais parents de cet enfant sont
également de grands sportifs nous allons
les retrouver à l'entraînement sur un
tapis de judo
depuis combien de temps pratiquez vous
le judo oh ça va faire maintenant une
douzaine d'années j'ai commencé à
eux-mêmes +51 qui n'était pas très
facile malgré vos charges familiales de
venir à la sole ou va c'est à dire que
les cours étant le soir à cet art une
fois les enfants qui étaient petits à
cette époque coucher ayant dîner je
pouvais très bien m'absenter comment
êtes vous venu à sur ce sport eh bien
mon mari m'a m'entraîner parce que il
mais ça et il trouvait que c'était
excellent pour moi il aimait ça et se
défend très bien puisqu'il est deuxième
de nuit
quel est votre professeur c'est monsieur
moreau il a fait il a passé deux ans au
japon et c'est un des meilleurs
professeurs de france eh bien nous
allons vous laisser en sa compagnie pour
nous faire une petite démonstration
allemande vient de monter sur le tapis
pour lui et son professeur est
immédiatement elle vient de faire un
s'appelle soto gari et maintenant un
mouvement de jambes italien de
fontainebleau par l'intérieur
pour commenter ces prises une ceinture
nous monsieur landais et une ceinture
noire 3e dan monsieur beauchamp au co
vie à chiba rail balayage des deux
jambes
[Musique]
kata guruma
rothau de l'épaule
vous avez des enfants et vous parlez
judo bien sûr mais ça remet bien sûr le
oui est ce que vos enfants pratiquent le
judo ils ont tous commencé actuellement
j'ai une fille qui ceinture orange et
deux petites qui viennent de commencer
cette année alors qu'ils ont ceinture
blanche encore vous espérez que patron
bientôt leur maman je ne sais pas enfin
j'espère que nous persévérons en tous
les cas quant à vous espérez vous un
jour être deuxième donne aux jeunes
inquiète pas maintenant des charges
familiales sont quand même un doute ou
lourde parce que les enfants sont plus
grands ils ont quand même davantage
besoin de moi à certains produits
protégés vous d'autres supports à la
tête natation
[Musique]